[Music]
Dylan thank you so much for being here
today thank you hi Forbes this is
amazing so tell me about what inspired
your days of girlhood videos and for
everyone who doesn't know can you please
explain what they are and what they
turned into sure days of girlhood was
sort of a video series that I started
because I was at the beginning of my
transition and I was looking to all
these iconic trans women but not knowing
how to get from point A to point B
and I thought okay well why not you know
take my followers Along on this journey
and it was originally supposed to just
sort of be like comedy it was supposed
to be light-hearted and fun and I think
over this last year I found a lot of
vulnerability and depth that I didn't
even know was there and it's been really
beautiful and and also hard at times but
I don't regret anything as a creative
what's it been like for you to then
shift from that creative mindset into
the the business side of things with
sponsored posts and promotions and
things like that I think I'm becoming a
bit of a
businesswoman as much as I I love the
the creative side I love getting smarter
I want to know everything and I want to
know how it all works I'm really
interested not you know of course being
in front of the camera but I I love the
idea of producing and and I just I think
why not learn it
all now I think for for me and for a lot
of people because you are so social
media forward and you're so out there a
lot of people kind of view you as the
spokesperson for the trans community did
you set out to do that when you started
these videos oh no I never wanted or
intended to be a spokesperson for the
community and I think I I just ask for
Grace as I'm learning so many things in
navigating this not only transness but
also this new found success it's
happened really fast and I think that's
what's so crazy about social media is I
think it kind of launches people at a
rate that not a lot of other mainstream
media does or can and I I really am now
looking to sort of not take a backseat I
want to stay really active in my
advocacy work but I want to decide when
where and how I'm going to show up as an
[Music]
activist switching back to the business
a little bit what is the one business
rule that you operate by no matter what
oh I love this my agent Stephanie she
always says don't react respond and so
if something happens in my life I often
will either at least sleep on it but
sometimes it's taking a few extra days
to really make sure that you know I'm
not coming out of a place of anger or
anxiety or frustration and that it's
it's purely who I am and can operate on
a really neutral
level you were you know in the spotlight
earlier this year after there was some
backlash with the sponsored post yes has
this experience affected who you partner
with going forward absolutely I now
realize that when I work with a brand
that they will forever be a part of my
story and so I want to make sure we're
on the same page going forward and I
want there to be a mutual respect and
not only for me but for my community
speaking of that one stat that I love to
bring up all the time is that the lgbtq
plus Community has nearly $4 trillion in
global purchasing power we've got the
purchasing power exactly yet brands are
still shying away from lgbtq plus
representation what would you say to
brands that that are despite this fact I
would say well that's a disappointment
because we're here and we're not going
anywhere and I also think that there are
brands that are interested in working
with someone like me but maybe don't
know how to you know or nervous to to
get involved or ask the wrong thing and
I say let's figure it out together let's
have these hard conversations because if
we don't then something beautiful can't
come from
it what do you want your legacy to be
oh I think I would like my legacy to be
this sort of idea of like celebrity 2.0
like how can we live in the spotlight
and you know have a large following but
try to do it in a way that feels like
the
kindest most rounded fun silly
empathetic vulnerable way possible and I
don't know if that can exist yet I'm I'm
still figuring that out and I think you
know there's certain circumstances where
I might get push back on that but I want
to see if we can do it
[Music]
differently